know sheep and goats they're really
different right like a sheep it just
follows its Shepherd right goats on the
other hand are are really finicky and
they're stubborn you know they want it
to do it their way they don't trust the
shepherd they they think they're going
to figure it out so a goat say for
example you had like an old car stereo
sitting out in your field which we had
somehow a car stereo had fallen out
under the grass and as one does as one
somehow a car stereo ends up in a field
um and the Sheep would stay away from it
but the goat would be like listen
I need to figure out what this thing is
I'm gonna eat it
and I think I love the metaphor for us
relying on our own understanding in a
way it's like you know what I got this
I'm gonna eat the car stereo I'll get
back to you and let you know what it is
you know